[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous présenter ice
watchot un film de Stanley Kubrick son
dernier film d'ailleurs et de film de
1980 avec Nicole Kidman et Tom Cruise
finalement kubrique on ne le présente
pas des réacteurs les plus des plus
grands acteurs de tous les temps et du
coup j'ai envie de vous parler non pas
des filles peut-être les plus connus que
soit 2001 où je shining ou autre mais
son dernier film qui est pas forcément
son film le plus accessible mais qui est
pour moi un film absolument incroyable
sur la relation de couple finalement
c'est une mise en abyme de de du
microcosme hollywoodien de la célébrité
de de comment on scrute les stars et ce
coup parce que à savoir que Tom Cruise
et Kidman était en couple dans la vraie
vie quand ils ont été cassés dans comme
couple dans ce film
kubrique à l'époque leur avait interdit
leur avait demandé si vous faites ce
film vous ne prenez aucun autre film
tant qu'on n'a pas fini celui-ci Kubrick
était effectivement comme on le connaît
très exigeant très personneliste faisait
parfois plus de 50 60 prises pour
certains plans
c'est aussi un film Queen n'a jamais vu
fini il est mort 3 mois avant la sortie
du film et donc il y a encore beaucoup
de débats sur à quel point le film qu'on
peut voir aujourd'hui était son final
cut ou est-ce que c'était un petit peu
modifié encore avant la sortie donc un
film entouré encore de plein de mystères
et c'est aussi un film qui est un petit
peu qui pour moi par un peu de rêver le
film est censé se passer à New York tout
a été rond en Angleterre le kubrique
avait une peur phobique de l'avion
refusait de voyager en avion et donc ils
ont recréé New York en Angleterre
complètement des rues entières etc donc
rien que pour ça voilà c'est un signe
qui vous interroge sur la nature du
cinéma sur ce qui est Hollywood sur sur
entre les images que l'on voit est-ce
que ça nous présente où se trouve la
réalité il y a encore une fois c'est
fait que toute la finesse de kubrique
etc on a beaucoup parlé du côté thriller
érotique du film qui évidemment un
aspect du film mais pour moi c'est
vraiment plus une exploration de ce que
c'est que le couple que c'est que des
relations avec des gens qu'on connaît
depuis de longues années et de cet
qu'est-ce que c'est que l'intimité dans
finalement dans un couple dans une
relation amicale ou
amoureuse et vraiment
dans Sims a voulu décortiquer montrer
tout cela presque au scalpel et avec
encore une fois un Tom Cruise et Kidman
absolument incroyable ou qui brille joue
sur l'ambiguïté entre le vrai couple
qu'il formait et le couple fictif qui
forme dans ce film donc voilà c'est un
film sur l'ambiguïté sur le rêve ou rien
de ce qu'on voit n'est ou en tout cas où
à chaque ou toutes les images qu'on nous
présente doivent être questionnés sur
notre rapport à la réalité et pour moi
un kubrique qui est plus en tout cas
j'allais dire j'avance en âge plus un
kubrique qui me plaît et qui est
impressionnant dans sa filmographie et
peut-être un de ses films les plus
aboutits thématiquement en tout cas
voilà
ice watchot de cette année qui brick
peut-être pas le premier choix quand on
découvre sa filmographie mais mais un
choix en tout cas très intéressant et
qui au-delà de cette thématique reste de
façon voilà que n'a fait que des
chaleurs donc un chef de stade légumes
[Musique]